tous les jours yvette a ressenti avec
violence le confinement doublé d'un
interdit de visite pour les familles des
personnes âgées dépendantes en centre de
soins
les ehpad en france elle a passé sa vie
adulte à s'occuper de sa mère madeleine
quand est venu le moment de la placer en
résidence dans cet ehpad de paris les
symptômes de sa maladie
neurodégénérative devenant trop lourd
pour elle seule elle était toujours là
auprès d'elle
puis la pandémie les portes du centre de
soins se sont refermées on ne sait pas
s'il ya des malades ont séparé le mur du
silence un silence qui a été rompu par
l'annoncé d'une nouvelle qu'elle
redoutait mardi dernier donc on
m'appelait pour me dire que maman allait
être dirigée
pour le coc vide à l'échelle du pays ce
sont plus de quarante mille personnes
âgées en ehpad et en établissements de
soins de longue durée qui présentaient
des symptômes du corps un navire us ce
mercredi
le nombre de morts explose près de 7000
on a l'impression d'un foutoir et d'une
d'une désorganisation qui continue au
sein même des dangers les plus graves
derrière la non organisation il y à la
vision de la personne âgée comme très
peu importante
maryse représente les familles des
bénéficiaires des pannes publique à
paris militante de longue date pour le
droit de ces derniers elle croit que le
système a échoué à protéger ce que l'on
dit pourtant être les plus vulnérables
depuis le début de la pandémie parce que
depuis longtemps ce sont ceux que l'on
ne voit plus la semaine dernière le
gouvernement a annoncé le début d'une
campagne massive de dépistage du
personnel et des bénéficiaires dans les
ehpad 2500 test devait être fait chaque
jour en région parisienne seulement mais
on n'en connais pas les résultats je
souhaite aussi que les hôpitaux et les
maisons de retraite puisse permettre
d'organiser pour les plus proches avec
les bonnes protections la visite aux
malades en fin de vie afin de pouvoir
leur dire adieu
yvette a bien entendu cette promesse du
président macro lundi mais ils n'y
croient pas je pense pas que les ehpad
soit prête à ouvrir leurs portes
je pense qu'il ya des choses qui ne
veulent pas qu'il soit lui dit tout
et donc on va continuer à vivre dans une
image ne sais pas pendant combien de
temps dans le drame
yvette crois qu'elle a une chance que
bien des familles n'auront pas sa mère
est morte non pas en ehpad
mais à l'hôpital et j'ai la chance de
pouvoir laisser un moment un petit
collier deux petites heures j'avais fait
pour noël tient que j'allais lui donner
pour son anniversaire puisqu'elle est
noeud plat des démarques le 9 avril et
qu'elle verrait son anniversaire le 10
avril ici marie ève bédard radio-canada
paris